I think a healthy dose of skepticism is
one of the most important attributes one
can have,
but also saying most of us could use a
little more of.
You guys know I'm big on definitions
around here,
so let's actually define the word
skepticism before we go any further.
An attitude of doubt or disposition to
incredulity either in general or toward
a particular object.
The doctrine that true knowledge or
knowledge in a particular area is
uncertain.
The method of suspended judgment,
systemic doubt or criticism,
characteristic of skeptics,
doubt concerning basic religious
principles as a mortality,
providence and revelation.
So all skepticism really is then is the
desire for more information before
making a judgment.
This seems like a really simple and
pretty obvious concept,
yet we're so lacking it in our public
discourse.
We're so quick to dismiss people.
The second they say something we don't
like.
We ignore evidence when it doesn't fit
our narrative,
and too often we pick sides when we
don't really know the facts.
This is why pundits on cable networks,
radio and online media or yelling all
the time,
instead of making a compelling argument
based on fact and reason,
they just yell with righteous
indignation.
So you think that what they're saying
must be true after all,
they're really fired up.
So they must have a true indecent cause,
right?
Well,
usually the opposite is true.
Of course,
it's not just these talking heads.
You could use a healthy dose of
skepticism.
We're in the midst of an election year,
so all of us should be skeptical of
everything.
Each one of these politicians running
for office says,
we shouldn't take their word for it.
Instead,
we should question whether what they're
saying is true,
and take the time to learn the facts.
Politicians prey on an uninformed,
uninterested,
and non skeptical electorate.
It's our job as citizens to make them
more honest and more forthright.
Pretty sure we all know they're not
gonna do that on their own.
Going even deeper.
It's not just pundits and politicians we
should be skeptical about,
but it's also our very selves.
The word skeptic even has a slight tinge
of negativity to it,
right?
Like,
oh,
he's a skeptic.
You better watch out for him.
All the skeptic actually wants is more
information to form an opinion on the
world in a rational way using facts and
proven methods.
Sure,
that's not as comforting as blind faith
and it certainly isn't as easy,
but perhaps the satisfaction is in the
journey of questioning.
My guest this week is Michael Shermer
and author who has written much on this
subject and as a thought leader in the
skeptic movement using science
improvable methods.
He talks about how we can have morality
that is based,
in fact,
not fiction.
It's a harder road,
but it is one that more and more people
seem to be taking.
It's also an idea I try to use in all my
interviews.
I'm the first to admit that I don't know
everything and I'm genuinely curious to
learn from people of all walks of life.
Talking directly to them is one of the
ways that we can actually do that.
One hundred 40 characters is nice,
but there's nothing like the true
personal connection.
At the end of the day,
none of us truly know the meaning of
life and the answer to the big questions
we can think we can guess we can create,
we can destroy,
but we simply cannot know.
It's the age old question that will
remain until the end of time in a way
not knowing is perhaps the most human
trait there is.
So when preachers,
politicians are conspiracy theorists
tell you they know what's really going
on,
just know that they're full of
something,
but it ain't knowledge.
Michael Shermer is the author of many
books,
the founding publisher of skeptic
magazine and is very skeptical of
everything I'm saying right now.
Welcome to the show.
You are a professional skeptic.
Yeah.
As a worrier.
Well,
given that I publish a magazine called
skeptical,
I guess that's technically
true.
Yeah.
And you run skeptic.com.
So you've got the.
We've got a book called skeptic right
here.
Yeah.
You're a skeptical dude.
I am not by nature necessarily.
I.
I would like to believe lots of things.
I'd like to believe that the stock
market is not catered cratering this
week.
You know,
I'd like to believe that,
uh,
you know,
aliens are out there and visiting us,
there's a lot of things.
If there was an afterlife,
you know,
I'd like to live for centuries to see
how all this turns out,
you know,
but the fact that I'd like it to be true
doesn't make it true,
so I have to kind of override my own
subjective biases and preferences in
favor of the facts,
which is sometimes hard to fake.
Yeah.
So I started the show by talking about
reason and using logic and science to
get a sense of morality,
which you've written a lot about.
But before we get into that,
I want to talk a little bit about your
history and your sort of evolution to
getting to where you are.
Uh,
so you weren't,
you didn't grow up religious,
right?
You became religious for a small period
of time around high school or late high
school.
Yeah.
Well,
I was a evangelical born again
Christian,
a in highschool and college for my four
years undergraduate.
And in the start of graduates,
let's talk about seven years total.
My parents weren't religious,
but they weren't antireligious,
you know,
back then the whole atheism thing was
not a thing.
It was just something that most people
didn't talk about.
But the born again movement was kind of
picking up in the seventies and my
friends were into it in high school,
so you know,
it's that,
that sort of after parental influence
and there's peer group influence and
that's was my case.
My friends were doing it.
I remember my friend frank was really
religious and when I became,
became a born again,
it happened at a Presbyterian church
because this other friend of mine went
there and when I came back to school on
Monday until Frank I did it,
I went to the Presbyterian church.
He goes,
no,
that's the wrong one.
Which one did he wait?
He was Jehovah witness.
Yeah.
So I'm like,
wrong one.
Oh,
okay.
So that was my first inkling that,
okay,
there's these little factions and tribes
even within the,
within the Christian Christianity
Movement and anyway,
but I take it fairly seriously.
And I went to Bible classes and then I
went to pepperdine,
which is a church of Christ school,
very conservative jury.
President Ford came to speak and you
know,
it was,
uh,
it was in a bubble where everybody
believed and you know,
when you're in the bubble
psychologically it makes sense,
logically coherent,
it's internally consistent and
everything falls into place.
And it's not really until you're out of
the bubble and you encounter other
worldviews that you think,
Huh,
you know,
maybe maybe mine's not so solid as I
thought.
And that was how I kind of chipped away
at it later.
Right.
So what kind of stuff were you
questioning before you got into the
bubble that led you to jumping in and
becoming born again?
And actually before you,
uh,
before I let you answer that,
when you're born again,
I always think of born again as someone
that's left the religion and comeback.
And that's why they are born again.
Born again,
just means
you're born physically and then you're
born again.
When you accept Jesus as your savior,
it's sort of a new.
You start life anew and you get eternal
life.
Because you've accepted,
Jesus says,
that's what they mean by born again and,
and evangelical.
They mean you were supposed to
evangelize.
So this is why evangelicals are always
talking to people about Jesus,
where they hold up the placards at
sporting events.
John Three 16,
for God so loved the world.
He gave his only begotten son for you.
And they,
they were the black face and football
with the three John Three 16,
right?
And then they thank God after they win.
Yeah.
So the idea is that,
uh,
you,
you wear it on your sleeve,
you know,
you're the,
the shining beacon on the hill.
You do not hide your faith underneath of
a Bushel basket to you tell people about
it in a way you kind of have a moral
obligation to do so because if you know
that this is the way,
the truth and the light and you get
eternal eternity for this person's soul,
you really have to tell them about it.
They're missing out.
So it's not like the old school,
like maybe George H,
w Bush's,
uh,
you know,
he was a methodist and they're pretty
quiet about it.
You know,
you believe what you believe.
I believe what I believe and we just
don't talk about it.
A evangelicals not like that.
They're more like h,
George,
w dot Bush,
you know,
you tell people Jesus was my favorite
philosopher and I'm a born again.
And you witnessed people literally going
door to door and I did that.
I've knocked justly.
So.
So you did all that and then you're in
the bubble.
And then what caused the chipping away
that led you to sit here?
Well,
I went to graduate school,
uh,
at cal state Fullerton,
which is a secular school and said,
and it's not.
Again,
it wasn't that atheism was a big thing.
It was just that no one was religious or
if they were,
they were quiet about it.
And so I began taking classes in social
psychology,
anthropology,
and I can see the psychological basis of
belief and where you happen to have been
born determines what you believe.
And particularly in anthropology,
you study all these indigenous peoples
who never even heard of Jesus Christ,
let alone Christianity or anything that
you know.
And it's like,
well,
why?
Why would they be condemned?
They didn't even know about it.
You know,
so.
Oh well,
they know God has a special place for
them.
Little waste station or something.
You know,
what about the Jews?
I mean they,
you know,
they believe pretty much everything I
believe.
But except Jesus.
Well,
if God has a special place,
okay,
well how does,
how does this all work?
You know?
And Yeah.
And then also the problem of evil.
I never thought that they see that Chris
Theologians provided a cogent answer to
that.
Why bad things happen to good people.
And I don't mean like homicide case that
we have a human nature.
We're sinful,
so people do bad things.
That's the quick answer to that.
Why childhood leukemia?
You know,
why tsunamis that wipe out entire
villages have tiny children that,
you know,
why should,
why do they have to suffer?
Sure.
And beyond the,
because God works in mysterious ways and
he has a plan for everybody,
which was never satisfying to me.
You know,
that pretty much did it in a.
and then finally,
while I wrote about this,
uh,
you know,
my girlfriend at the time was in a car
accident and broke her back and uh,
and I was pretty much on the way out at
that point,
but I remember it being at the emergency
room thinking this poor woman.
I mean,
she is the sweetest lady and w why would
this happen to her?
This is not right,
you know,
so I sort of made one last ditch effort
and prayed,
you know,
and it,
it's not that this was the big test and
if it fails and I won't believe it,
it's just like,
you know,
what course he's still paralyzed today.
And I was like,
okay,
I,
you know,
I just don't think there's anybody up
there pulling the strings.
Yeah.
So why do you think so many people are
just afraid to say,
I don't know,
because that seems to me to be the real
question and the real basis of sort of
everything that you do.
You're not proclaiming to know any sort
of wisdom that I don't know.
Right?
I mean,
we,
we know different things,
but you're not proclaiming to have the
answers and people are so afraid of that
question.
What do you,
what do you think that's about?
Uh,
well,
I think cognitively we know now that
once you comprehend a,
an idea,
a concept,
uh,
anything,
the brain automatically just believes it
to be true.
Just accepts it as part of the factual
world that is.
And then being skeptical of it or
saying,
I don't know.
I'm not sure I challenges is an extra
cognitive load.
You can do it.
Lots of people do.
So think of the difference between type
one and type two thinking type one.
Cognition is rapid,
intuitive,
instinctive,
emotional type two thinking is
deliberate,
slow,
methodical,
rational,
and,
and most of our thought processes that
we initiate our type one,
we just kind of a feeling about things
we gut instinct go about the world and
type two requires,
okay wait,
let me stop and think about maybe I
shouldn't make that investment.
Maybe I'd better not marry this person.
Maybe I shouldn't buy that company.
Whatever it is that requires additional
steps.
So that's an extra cognitive load.
It's uncomfortable,
it takes time.
Um,
and uh,
anyway.
Uh,
and that's true with religious beliefs
think,
you know,
it just feels like,
the earth is the center of everything.
We're,
we're the center of creation.
God's here for me,
it,
it just,
you know,
everything that happens,
happens for a reason.
It just kinda feels right.
So it's really just,
I mean it's just as simple as comfort
really is what you were saying.
It's just like there is some stuff out
there that I don't understand and I
better just pick this belief because
then I don't have to spend that much
mental energy.
It's almost like a,
you know,
the creationist arguments or arguments
with people about,
you know,
who built the pyramids or whatever.
It's just,
well God did it or the aliens did it.
And then,
and then for me to deconstruct the whole
thing,
like in a debate or on a TV show,
you know,
I have to go through,
well,
how do you know what happened?
I got 15 minutes to explain natural
selection or,
you know,
whatever.
It's just easier to go,
oh,
God did it man.
So there's some of that.
Also,
the way our technology works now,
we're twitter of 140 characters and
buying of six seconds and all of these
things.
Those are what you just described it.
Those are type one thinking,
right?
Because it's just quick easy stuff and
this I guess is type two where we're
actually going in and out of an idea,
but in a way it would be really hard for
type two to ever win the great debate,
right?
You just don't have time.
It does win,
but it takes time and it's delivered and
it takes effort.
It's uncomfortable.
You know,
sam is a doctoral thesis,
was based on this idea of scanning
brains while they read a while.
People read statements that are
obviously true,
obviously fall through.
You can't tell,
you just don't know any show that,
uh,
that,
that the brain activity is very rapid
and simple and easy and positively
reinforced with dopamine for questions
that were obviously true or false.
The ones where you had to deliberate on
and so on,
where the areas of the brain that lit
up,
we're not,
not only did it happen slower,
but they were associated with things
like bad smell and discussed and
negative emotions,
so really you know,
an idea that stinks or an idea that's
been,
in other words,
being skeptical saying,
I now comprehend this and I doubted it's
a little bit like why line is
cognitively a heavier load because you
have to know what the truth is and then
take another step and go,
okay,
now I'm going to manipulate the truth in
this particular way and I have to
remember both of those and then maybe
you tell it to a third person.
Now you've got three different stories
you've got,
so that load gets heavier and it's
harder and it's just easier to go the
simple route.
Yeah.
Did you happen to see Sam's blog post
around Christmas time about lighting,
lighting a fire?
Oh yes.
It was a really interesting piece
because a lot of what we're talking
about,
it's not just couched in religion.
I think that's what his point was that
he said he was saying that we're all
comforted by a nice fireplace fire,
but then he goes into the carcinogens
and toxins and all this horrible stuff
and I read it that day and then I did
light a fire to that.
I think it was.
I think I read it on Christmas Eve and I
lit a fire and I think it illustrated
his point perfectly.
Like we have this idea,
we really like the fire,
right?
It's a really nice comforting thing and
then we can cognitively know that it's
doing a lot of damage to us.
So not all crazy beliefs and crazy
actions are sort of based in religion.
That's right.
I mean it goes across the spectrum.
Again,
aliens or deities for atheist is like
all of them were even if you don't
believe in God,
but there's somebody out there who is
looking out for us,
who knows we're here,
you know,
loves this.
Maybe looking out for us morally,
something like that.
That's kind of how aliens are described
in a way.
It is like somebody cares about me.
It's like the fire,
it makes you feel good.
The afterlife is like that as well.
You know,
we're all set.
Scores are settled,
you know,
were,
were you get to have the perfect body
and you're 29 years old and uh,
you know,
and so on and,
and,
and all justice is served and that just
feels good.
I mean,
that's the way the world should be and
you can just look around and go,
well,
it isn't.
So,
you know,
it's so funny what people take comfort
in because just this past weekend I was
watching the history channel that,
you know,
they've gone from what once was history,
now they do a lot of God stuff,
right?
So I think it was God versus the devil
is the name of the show or God first God
versus Satan or one of these things.
And there was so much horrible imagery,
you know what I mean?
Burning people and endless war and
armageddon and all this stuff.
And I kept thinking the entire time.
This is incredible to me.
I mean this is what people are taking
comfort in what it was pretty horrible
stuff.
So that right there shows a cognitive
system
well.
So part of that is that we're also
moralizing animals,
moralizing primates,
we care deeply about justice and right
and wrong.
So it's not just we want a good life and
easy life,
a life with plenty of food and water and
milk and honey and you know,
the,
it's not just that we want to,
we want to cause we can be behind that
we feel is a good cause and all causes
have to have an antique cars,
you know?
Well.
So who's preventing us from achieving
this utopia?
And it's those guys,
those bad guys over there,
you know,
and,
and they're preventing us from having
eternal bliss forever.
How bad are they?
They are really bad.
And what does that mean?
We can do to them whatever we want
because they're so bad.
And that's what leads to genocide and
wars and conflicts.
Even homicides,
you know,
90 percent of homicides are moralistic
in nature.
That guy deserved to die.
Why?
Well,
he scratched my car,
he insulted me or he stole my girlfriend
or you know,
whatever.
They're always these,
these kind of moralistic reasons.
So it was an interesting commentary on
this,
uh,
recently about the interest in trump and
other strong leaders and then reflecting
back on the interest of in Mussolini and
Hitler Back in the thirties and George
orwell writing about this saying,
I really get this.
You can see the passion and the people.
It's not just that Hitler or Mussolini
said I will give you economic prosperity
and jobs and in three square meals a
day,
it's that we are going to change the
world.
We are going to make Germany great
again,
are really great.
So it's about easy answers.
Then right?
Again,
going to your type one thinking and
these guys like trump that just black
and white,
black and white,
simple simple stuff.
So how do we,
and this is I guess really what you've
done sort of more than how do we wrestle
that conversation back and get it to a
place where people are willing to
extrapolate ideas and,
and open them up and get in there and
really figure out what's going on.
How do we do it?
Well,
you do what we're doing now,
but most people don't sit down like
this,
you know,
you go to a bar or whatever and it's,
it's much more black and white and in
part I think the diffusion of culture
through the Internet and all the radio
stations and television stations helps,
you know,
despite the,
a history channel two with the ancient
alien and stuff,
you know,
it's like,
are all formally all Hitler all the
time.
Now it's all conspiracy then is all
bigfoot foot.
Then it's all aliens.
Yes,
I know,
but at least there's.
And I love that stuff,
but what we're going to talk a little
bit about,
I love that stuff,
but I know that,
you know,
they're just playing with your mind.
It's good to remember.
Television is a series of commercials
with blank spots in between.
They have to be filled with something
interesting to keep you from the
clicker.
The clicker culture.
Uh,
so.
Well,
and then literacy rates,
the more of that,
more literate people are,
the more they read,
the more options they have.
So it's true twitter,
140 characters,
but you can embed a link to an article
that maybe is 3000 words and then maybe
from there you go to the 10,000
word analysis from there you go to the
book.
And so any.
As a book author,
I,
I like to think maybe I'm dilute
delusional here that people still like
to read long books.
I hope and move from the twitter to,
you know,
to face.
But listen,
I,
I hope so too.
That's why I'm doing this and that's
exactly what I'm doing this.
So it's interesting.
You're talking about why people have
done bad things in the name of morality,
but how do we get morality than without
religion?
How do we using science,
and this is what you've written a lot
about,
how do we use science to get some sense
of morality so we don't end up doing the
same things that the religious people
are doing?
Right?
Well,
so.
Well it starts with the idea,
the recognition that that moral values
are part of our human nature.
We have a sense of right and wrong and
justice and it's built into us and you
can see it in all humans and actually
all primates,
even other mammals like elephants and
dogs and so on.
They have a sense of guilt and,
and uh,
and shame and things like that.
And,
and they,
and they have a certain amount of
empathy,
sympathy,
cooperativeness as well as selfishness
ingredient and so on.
They have these suite of moral emotions
maybe scaled down from what we have,
but so it's there in our nature.
We evolved it,
we got it as part of the package of just
being human.
And then.
So that was just a survival thing,
right?
Like just a Darwin,
like you have to play nice with people,
otherwise they're going to.
Exactly.
Okay.
So you start with something like a
Dawkins' selfish gene model and you
know,
what,
what does,
what would a self replicating molecule
to perpetuate itself into the future?
It,
it needs to be build a,
a cell to put itself in and then
multiple cells and then an organism,
you know,
survival machine to carry it forward.
So our bodies are behold into the the
genes we are the genes survival machine.
And so why shouldn't I just be as
selfish and greedy as I possibly can,
hoard all the resources,
take all your stuff in our knock you on
the head and take you know well,
because you would do the same
calculation is me and I know that you
know that I might be thinking that and I
know that you know that I know that you
might be thinking that and so therefore
maybe it's better if I'm just nice to
you and,
but I can't just fake and pretend I'm a
nice person because in time you will
pick up the cues,
subtle cues that I,
I'm not genuine in my feelings about
you.
I'm,
I'm just coldly manipulating your
emotions to get something in time.
People can see that in other people.
So you can't just fake it.
You have to actually believe it and
actually feel like I want to be a good
person.
And,
and so you have that tension.
Then the good moral emotions and the
dark side of emotions and they're there
for all of this.
So isn't that strange though,
because that does show sort of,
you're giving me the scientific
explanation of why to be good and then
at the same time that is sort of why
religion would tell people to be good to
write to,
to better their community or to work
with people or that kind of thing.
So there is some place that you could
use both of those things?
Well,
I,
I think what religions discovered this
by,
by trial and error over thousands of
years,
there are certain things that we
shouldn't do because most people don't
like it.
You know,
so you know,
killing and you know,
this kind of thing.
Even though there's a lot of bands
Bible,
they kind of figured out,
look,
we're a community so we need a set of
rules.
You know,
maybe we disagree about the rules,
but Dang it,
we need the rules and everybody has to
obey him.
And if it,
if not,
then there'll be punishments.
And if you think you got away with it
because there was no one around,
there's an eye in the sky,
you know,
this is in a way,
that basis of God beliefs and in part
there's multiple reasons for God,
but that's one of them.
There's,
you know,
there's a moral eye in the sky keeping
track.
Now,
if you're a psychopath and know care.
Well,
all right,
it's not gonna work for you,
but for the bulk of the population that
would work.
And so in a way,
you know,
the conservative Christian belief in the
sinful nature of humans is in,
in a way a Darwinian model as well
because yes,
we're greedy and we,
if we think we can get away with it,
we might.
So in a sort of like a prisoner's
dilemma,
Game Theory Type Model,
uh,
you know,
tit for tat in,
okay,
I'll start off cooperating and if you
cooperate I'll cooperate again.
But if you defect that I'm gonna,
I'm gonna nail you for that.
So that,
that desire to,
to,
to nail you,
to get justice for the thing you did,
that was wrong.
That's actually a good strategy.
You know the Gandhian turn the other
cheek,
Jesus turned the other cheek.
That's not a good game theory strategy
because that just means you'll be
exploited by other people.
Right.
It never works out well for that person.
Unfortunately it doesn't and it won't
work for a whole society that those
kinds of societies won't survive because
other groups will or clans or whatever.
We'll try,
we'll take them over so it actually
helps to cultivate a reputation of being
a bad ass.
You know,
you take my stuff,
I'm going to kick your ass.
Woo.
Okay.
All right.
Sure.
I'm all right.
Well,
okay,
well you're coming from
to that point,
using a moral compass,
right?
I mean you're,
you're saying I'm doing this sort of for
myself,
but that in itself is sort of for the
greater good.
Right?
Well,
but it's a bite.
The greater good.
It turns out to be a byproduct,
but I think there's evolutionary
arguments you can make that,
but that actually really is good for the
group.
Not a group selection argument.
Just that the more of us individuals
that are cooperating within our group,
our group will be better off for that
group is not the target of selection,
still the individuals,
but societies are better off.
And so what I argue in the moral arc is
that over the centuries,
uh,
tweaking social,
political and economic systems this way
and this way,
we've been kind of hovering around this
idea that there is a better way to live
for in a utilitarian type or more of us
will be better off and live longer and
prosperous and healthy lives if we do
this.
Rather than that,
you know,
that a democracy versus a dictatorship,
a relatively free markets of trading and
allowing people to do it their thing
versus a command and control economy
like in North Korea or having a set of
rules and the rule of law and a police
force has good,
good,
good fences,
make good neighbors.
So we,
we've been doing this,
these experiments.
So that's what I mean.
It's kind of like a science.
It's like,
okay,
let's run the experiment and see how it
goes.
And then we'll tweak the variables in
four years called an election and we'll
try it again.
And there's no,
they're there to get there.
There's no utopia.
We're just trying to make a little bit
of progress.
So we'll increase taxes there and lower
him there.
Will will change the gun control flaws
here but not there.
And we'll seat list to see what happens.
Right.
So you're saying when politicians
promise they can fix everything.
They're not actually.
Yeah.
Well that's what you're saying.
It's a shocker.
I know.
What do you.
What do you make of people that would
believe everything that you've said that
lived their lives in a secular way using
science and reasoning and their own
personal morality to guide their lives,
but at the same time do take that leap
of faith and still believe in some crazy
stuff.
Still believed that maybe there's
someone upstairs watching them.
Because I think.
I think that's probably where most
people fall that they do live their
lives based in secular ideas,
but at the same time if you really sat
them down and said,
well,
you know,
because people want to believe at the
end that they're going to go and play
tennis with God,
right?
Will there be competition in heaven?
This is what I want to know because if
it's too boring,
there's nothing to do with challenges,
but then it wouldn't be worried.
It wouldn't be worth it to you,
but what do you make of that type of
person?
It's a super good point.
In reality,
most say conservative Christians today
are more liberal socially than liberals
were in the fifties say,
but they don't even know it.
They,
they,
they're just like,
well,
I,
I'm doing this because it says so in the
Bible and I'm a Christian,
and Jesus,
you know,
it was like that.
He said,
you know,
Jesus should love all the gays and
blacks,
and so it was like,
where does he say that and where are you
getting this?
But I know where they're getting.
They're getting from culture.
That's been shifting for decades from
the bottom up,
just from everybody changing the way
they talk and think about shows or
presented a scripts are written novels,
books and so forth and all of us have
changed our,
our expanded,
our moral sphere to be more encompassing
and so that the standouts like the,
the Donald Sterling's of the world,
who insults African-americans is the
owner of the clippers.
This,
you know,
his life is just ruined for this idiotic
statements.
But most,
all the guys back in the fifties used to
think like him.
My Dad was Kinda like that and it's
like,
dad can't say that anymore.
Is that one of the scary things about
society's changing too quickly?
I mean,
I know I,
I follow you on twitter and you do push
against some of this regressive left
stuff and some of the social justice
warrior stuff because in a way they're
gonna come for us to.
Things will keep changing.
And then some of the things that you're
saying right now that don't sound
controversial at all,
to me,
depending on the way we evolve in the.
Depending on the way ideas,
you know,
the way that they move throughout time,
someone 20 years from now could look at
this and say,
ah,
you see schermer was a real big it for
some reason.
We can't even think of it.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah,
of course we,
you know,
we worry about that or wonder about
that.
Uh,
you know,
we look back on say the debates about
interracial marriage.
It's like what were they thinking?
Right?
And,
and just,
you know,
the last year,
looking back at gay marriage,
what were they thinking?
We know what their thinking is so
recent.
And so,
but now what are we thinking now that in
20 years people go,
what the,
what were here?
So yeah,
look at that.
I think about that all the time.
I'm tweeting out all this stuff all the
time and he's 20 years from now,
someone going to go,
man,
that guy was a complete lunatic.
And they might be saying it now.
Well we don't know because we're buried
in the culture.
It's just hard to say.
I will say just projecting forward
maybe,
um,
the rights of the unborn in here.
I don't mean fetuses,
I mean future generations to inhabited
earth that's habitable.
That is there's resources available and
so on.
So the environmental movement I think is
part of that.
Uh,
you know,
that would be one area.
Artificial intelligence is maybe another
one is data a person,
you know,
do they have personhood?
Yeah,
those kinds of things I think we can
think about those are not particularly
controversial.
Uh,
the social justice warriors,
so called the regressive left.
It's an interesting term that's really
caught on.
Um,
that was a measure.
Yeah.
So I thought,
I think it's very effective.
That's an example of how far for first
of all,
how far we've come,
how much moral progress we've made.
That the biggest thing on your plate as
a college student is to protest
costumes.
Really.
That's it.
That's good.
That means things are pretty dang good.
So is that the part that we need to
focus on more than.
Because I do think that,
you know,
we all get in this big workup frenzy
over this stuff and they sent out this
letter and you know,
they didn't want them to wear offensive
Halloween costumes or something.
So to that,
if you just look at it in that narrow
view,
it's like,
Oh shit,
free speech is really being attacked,
but if you look at it,
and I think this is what you're saying,
if you look at it from the broader
spectrum,
it's like,
well,
look what's left now we're just fighting
over Halloween costumes.
So in that sense,
things really have progressed really
well.
Exactly right.
You compare it to say what students were
protesting in the sixties,
seventies,
and uh,
again,
that's science.
But also the,
these moral pendulums tend to swing back
and forth to one extreme to the other.
And I think it has gone too far now.
I mean,
uh,
you know,
it seems like free speech as a moral
principle is being trumped by other
moral values that some people hold the
right to not hear something
uncomfortable or offensive or something
like that.
I was arguing this back in the nineties
with the Holocaust deniers when I wrote
my book on the gated them when they were
kind of big and Canada had anti
Holocaust denial laws.
It was incorporated under their hate
speech laws.
I remember first reading about this
going,
hate speech.
What?
Why is that hates if you're Jewish.
I could see,
but,
but who's actually being harmed by this?
These guys,
you could just just shine a light on
him.
You just black.
They are and they'll go nowhere because
they don't have anything.
Why suppress them and lock them up?
And then I remember when David Irving
got arrested in Austria,
he didn't even say anything.
He was just going to give a lecture and
hitch hitchins defended him publicly and
I thought,
that's good.
You know this case free speech.
Trump's so called hate speech because
the problem is who determines what's
hate?
Hateful.
Sure.
And doesn't that hitch defending him?
You debating these people in and
allowing for these terrible ideas.
Right?
We all know the Alec has happened.
This is a terrible idea to deny it,
but doesn't that show you that,
that the secularists are pretty
consistently on the right side of things
that we are the ones that are defending
ideas even when they are scary to us and
things that we don't like.
Most of people do what most of us,
but people don't know if you do
something that's against the religion,
generally religious people aren't going
to defend you were secularists will,
they'll stand up for the idea.
Right?
So I'm religious do defend free speech
and,
and they're willing to allow their,
allow their religion to be criticized.
Uh,
but for the most part,
most of us sort of circle the wagons and
protect our group or whatever.
And so it takes an extra effort.
It's sort of that type to collectors.
Wait a minute.
Free speech is really important.
So you have to sort of run through the
arguments that a John Stuart mill made
in his on liberty that,
okay,
what if they're right?
Okay.
They can't be right.
Yeah.
But what if they're right?
Just like a little bit,
you know,
then you'll learn something.
And,
and second,
um,
a second,
you could learn something from just the
debate,
you know,
just the,
just how,
how confident are you in your arguments?
Can you explain evolution by natural
selection in five minutes in a debate
because that's what you gotta do,
opening statement,
rebuttal,
rebuttal q and a boom,
boom,
can you do it?
And,
and when you actually have to do it like
this,
in the case of debating creationist,
boy,
I really sharpened my skills about how
do I know that evolution happen?
What are the four best arguments we
have?
And it's actually kind of a good
exercise in that sense.
But mostly it's just let this guy talk
and the whole room can see how idiotic
these arguments are.
Just go for it,
dude.
Right?
Isn't that a little bit like when the,
who's that creation is that.
Did the ham it when Ken Ham debated Bill
Nye,
right?
And it was like,
this was actually ridiculous and all he
had to do is just let him hang himself.
But we're so afraid of doing that.
Are we so afraid of just letting someone
go?
And,
and
it's counterintuitive,
it doesn't feel like we should do,
we should circle the wagons and smack
them down.
But yeah,
no,
it's actually better if you don't,
if you just provide better arguments and
let the world see,
you know,
how bad those arguments are.
And yes,
maybe he'll convince a few people,
but in the long run truth will win out,
you know,
the bright light of reason will,
will shine,
right.
I'm pretty sure he was just trying to
sell tickets to that,
the park or whatever that good
intention.
And you know,
some fundraising for his arc park,
which I see as going forward today.
A boy,
I don't know,
Bill,
I know bill,
Bill's a good friend and uh,
you know,
he,
he had some doubts about whether he
should do it or not.
I think in the long run it was a good
thing to do.
He did a good job
because there's a fear of debating these
people because then you could end up
debating every crackpot ever.
Right?
Because it was always.
And we see this is something that I see
every now and again.
I'll see you argue with someone on
twitter or or some of the other people
that are arguing with somebody and it's
like,
man,
how much energy,
and I'll do it sometimes too.
How much energy should we put in to
debating people either that have,
you know,
just ideas that are terrible or aren't
debating from an honest place or that
you know,
we're going to twist your words after
and there's a certain opportunity costs
with that.
Yeah,
there is.
And so one of the criteria I use is to
what extent do people care about the
subject is an influencing thing.
Is it being disgusted the in the
political debates at currently or is it
in the newspapers?
So like in the Holocaust deniers,
back in the nineties,
it was kind of a big thing.
They were on a donahue.
Yeah.
And Montel Williams and they were,
you know,
there's articles written about them in
time and Newsweek and New York Times and
the Schindler's list came out and it was
big debates.
They were challenging it and there was
articles about us.
I thought,
you know what?
It's time for us to engage that.
What are they claiming?
What,
what exactly?
So they actually gave me this list,
39,
uh,
arguments that holocaust historians
cannot answer.
I said,
all right,
give me the list.
So I actually went down and just worked
my way through the list and a lot of
them were hard to find actually.
And went in a lot of his holocaust
historians that I consulted,
they did not know the answers to these
things.
And now we know because,
you know,
I,
there's one out and track these things
down.
And uh,
you know,
Richard Evans did this in the,
in Irving's trial.
David Irving sued Deborah Lipstadt for
calling.
I'm a denier now,
here's an interesting sociological thing
because I've always called David Urbina
Holocaust Denier,
but he likes me because we've gone out
for beer and dinner before and I engage
him and I talked to him.
David said,
what,
what's going on with you working on now?
So we had this thing.
So he doesn't,
he likes me.
He did like Lipstadt because she,
she's nasty tumor,
didn't talk to him or was it?
So,
uh,
one of the things I like to do is as an
investigator,
um,
I shouldn't call it an experiential
journalists because Sean Penn could do
it.
Maybe I could do it.
You sort of get out there and you talk
to people and really they do open up if
you're nice and respectful to them,
friendly,
you know.
So just tell me about this.
What is it you think is going on because
I don't really understand the arguments
and then they'll kind of open up and
then if you could give him a few beers,
they'll start talking about,
you know,
oh the Jews,
the Jews are doing.
Oh really?
Tell me more.
So is that how you ended up sort of
beating him in the public space that you
got to know the guy you were able to
sort of unravel some of the arguments
and I would guess that it's one of those
things where you can just get,
when you pull out one little pin,
the rest of it starts to
exactly right.
I say beat,
but just you sort of lay it out there.
Here's what he said,
here's what he did.
Here's his arguments and so on,
and it just let the arguments speak for
themselves and I think they do.
And so those guys are largely gone now
and the creationists,
you know,
they're still hanging on,
the poll numbers are starting to shift
and the whole young Earth creationism is
largely being marginalized,
you know,
the Ben Carson's of the world,
seventh day adventist.
So they're young earth creation.
This is where all this silliness about
the pyramids come from.
It's because he's a seventh day
adventist and it follows from these
other beliefs that he holds about
genesis and all that.
Uh,
but,
but you can see he's not going anywhere
and he's just one and more popular is
either pretty mainstream or really not
very religious centrus like trump.
Um,
you know,
I think,
I think the power of the moral majority
is passed.
I don't think to get elected you have to
be an uber religious person anymore.
Yeah.
You know,
so trump was just at liberty university
and this is a guy who by any estimation
that I've ever seen,
has no real religious religious Osetra
to him as not even worried.
But he was up there and he's like,
yeah,
there was definitely an extra s in
there,
but he's in there.
He's at Liberty University and he's
quoting scripture,
wrongly apparently made mocked up a
couple things,
but I was thinking this is really what's
wrong with our political system really
in,
in the most perfect way because here's a
guy who,
for whatever,
all the reasons that people like him is
because he's saying things very clearly,
whether the,
you know what I mean,
whether it's true or not,
he's just saying.
And here even he who says I'm beholden
to no one has to pander still to the
religious rights.
So we're not fully out of it.
Yeah,
no,
for sure.
But yeah,
you have to have a little bit of it,
but it's not,
that's not what's going to win the
election.
I think it's going to be the centrist
votes this time,
which is more secular,
just more real world problems,
you know,
that kind of thing.
Anyway,
so,
but it's still there.
It's an inch.
Another interesting,
you know,
that it seems to be the Republicans,
the right are the ones identifying,
um,
you know,
the problem of terrorism,
what,
what's behind it,
you know,
there's certain religious beliefs that
are behind it.
Now.
It's true.
I know some of the Isis fighters are
young men out for money and sex and
adventure and whatever,
but,
but underneath it is,
you know,
that sort of apocalyptic in other
worldly Utopian society.
This,
you know,
this kind of really quasi religious
beliefs that are driving them and it's
the left that doesn't seem to want to
acknowledge that they're so afraid of
this.
Again,
political correctness run amok,
so afraid to use the word.
Our own president won't use the word and
he's a guy I admire.
He's obviously very bright and thinks
that he's a type two thinker all the
way.
Maybe it'd be better if he sometimes use
type one.
Sure.
At least in this instance,
because then he would at least say the
word,
but yeah,
this is coming out of the left.
So I,
I'm a liberal.
What do I do about this?
This has been the theme throughout the
four or five months that we've been
doing this.
Sure.
I understand.
I've watched it and I think you're doing
exactly what you have.
What we have to do is push back and you
just push that pendulum back and if
enough of us do that,
uh,
then,
then it will get knocked back and people
will stop saying those.
They'll start identifying things
correctly,
I think.
Yeah.
Why do you think the left is so hung up
on this one issue so that if,
anytime,
you know,
I was just watching some another program
where after the Cologne,
a sex attacks,
right,
a thousand men and there were rapes and
all this terrible stuff that immediately
the argument became,
well,
you know,
Christians do bad stuff to and you know,
the West done this and we've bombed this
or that,
this sort of knee jerk reaction to make
everything in this moral equivalence and
sort of make everything about us.
Whether when it had it been a thousand
Christians that had done this,
they never would have flipped it the
other way.
So what do we do?
I mean,
we,
we just kept talking about it.
Okay,
well a couple things.
First of all,
why?
Why do they do well?
Because as Steven pinker points out in
the blank slate,
that blank slate model that you know,
that culture determines everything and
otherwise people are equal.
That's more of a left wing and right
wing view of human nature.
Conservative Christians have more of a
realistic,
Steve Calls a realistic model of human
nature.
That is both genetics and culture and,
and uh,
and,
and second,
uh,
that again,
this all inclusiveness,
we don't want to offend other people
because look what w,
w,
what were you doing to blacks in the
fifties and sixties and Jews in the and
forties and that was really bad.
Okay.
So that's sort of taking a principle and
then running with it,
right?
No one's denying that that's a fact.
Yes,
that's right.
Yeah.
And so therefore it would be wrong to
stereotype all Muslims and,
but it gets to the point where even if
you say,
if you preface every sentence with,
of course most Muslims are good and nice
and moral people that would never do
this,
but then you can't even get past that.
But what,
but what now my wife is from Cologne,
Germany.
She's German and she just moved here
last year and married me and we live
here now.
But her,
uh,
we were going to go to Cologne next
month for carnival and now we're not
going because she's worried about
really.
And her mother was just attacked about a
week ago.
So this is a week after,
two weeks after the new year's thing.
And there's a lot of this going on
that's not being reported because
they're afraid to use the word to say
because her mom was attacked by an Arab
looking Syrian man who said he mumbled
something about Western wham and grabbed
her breast and,
and really offensive bottle of booze.
You know,
it's a lot of these young men that are
drunk and they're sort of using as an
excuse to what extent they're really
religious.
Who knows?
Sure.
It's a confluence of a zillion things,
but that's why we have to talk about.
Exactly.
Right.
Yeah.
So is that where,
where,
where is that going?
Right.
Yeah.
So we're going,
oh,
I'm Angela Merkel,
who I've admired very much.
I think maybe she just went too far.
Uh,
you,
that we have to do some screening,
but the moment you say screening,
then you.
Are you talking about targeting certain
people and,
and isn't that stereotyping and doesn't
that lead to genocide?
Okay.
So you ended up down that road,
but just,
just take a little step.
Just a little.
Just a tiny bit to find out what's going
on here before.
That's why trump made that comment and
he's felt a bigot and a racist.
But wait,
he's just saying maybe we should just
figure out what's going on here.
First.
Clean.
It gets twisted into something and I'm
not defending what he says at all.
And that's,
that's also why language is so important
to this because we've gotten so afraid
of saying anything the wrong way or
writing anything the wrong way that
you'll immediately be labeled a bigot
and a racist.
And the rest of it,
when all you're saying is we should have
some decent screening to figure out
who's here.
And you're also giving me a firsthand
example.
I mean,
your wife's mother was attached,
so this isn't,
this isn't made up stuff.
No.
And this,
you know,
it's cold.
She's 65 year old woman all bundled up
and umbrella and hat and jacket and
everything.
And so it's not like they're out groping
young women in bars wearing miniskirts.
It's just grabbing anything that's
female and you know,
so who knows what the motivations are,
you know,
some of it again is just young men on
just on a rampage,
but you know.
But again,
I think it's not just random who's doing
it and everybody's afraid to say what it
is.
And so merkel who I think has been a
great leader,
I think she just gone too far.
Yeah.
What do you make of the situation?
I wasn't planning on going here,
but I'm glad we were taking this road
that Germany,
a lot of people are saying,
and I've had a lot of people email me
about this,
that they're saying that the reason that
they opened the borders the way they did
was because there's this guilt because
of the Holocaust,
so they don't want to see people,
you know,
if they,
if they can help,
they want to help,
but now it's gotten out of control and
now what this is going to do is,
is help the far right.
We're seeing hints of this here with,
with trump and xenophobia and we're
seeing this all over Europe now.
So again,
it's when the left doesn't deal with
things honestly,
that we allow the
right.
Exactly right.
I mean if the left wants to defend their
position,
they should do the opposite what they're
doing because it's the right that are
going to sweep sweep in.
So my wife tells me that the sentiments
in Germany about this and before this
attitudes toward Israel and the Middle
Eastern conflicts is that we just have
to bite our tongue because what we did
was so bad that we just have to always
support Israel.
And even though there's,
there's numbers of people in branches,
in the society that do not support
Israel,
they can't say anything.
And uh,
and even though there are debates about
Palestinians and who's doing what and
who's the real terrorist and you know,
no one has perfectly clean hands in
those,
in that conflict.
Uh,
but in Germany you can't,
you can't say this because of the guilt.
There's a lot of guilt.
Uh,
and they've had,
you know,
they've paid reparations to Israel for a
long time and uh,
you know,
so Merkel's try to navigate around.
It's very difficult to do.
And so in part there's that,
but also they're the,
they're the strongest nation of the EU.
And she was trying to set a precedence.
And I see,
I see why she was trying to do that.
But I just think it probably gone too
far.
And now there's a lot,
my wife tells me there's a lot of these
strong right Nazi type groups that are
now bubbling up saying,
see,
I told you I
don't do well actually next week I have
Tommy Robinson on who's the former head
of the edl who marginalized.
So you mentioned earlier at one point
helped get him out of the edl because he
felt it was too far.
Right.
And there were some Neo Nazi element and
he had emailed me about coming on the
show and I had a real sort of debate
within myself whether here's someone who
I know a lot of people think he's just a
racist and then I get a lot of people
that say,
you know,
he's,
he's talking about things that people
don't want to talk about.
And I felt,
well if I talked to him are people gonna
think I'm a racist.
And then that was why I felt like I had
to do the interview and I have to
really.
Because I can't be afraid of just the
conversation and where that's going to
replace me.
But that's,
that's where they've got us.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah,
well,
but,
but they're not,
they don't have this.
There we are talking about it and you
will do that and we will push back and
that's a good thing.
Yeah.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
so it,
it in,
in Germany and Europe,
you know,
they've made a major transition from 500
years of very tribal and balkanized
constantly in conflict history to,
you know,
a completely different kind of society.
And so when these tensions have been
bubbling up,
you know,
the temptation is to go back and,
but then the,
then the put,
no,
we don't want to do that because look
what happened.
This led to all these conflicts,
genocides and so on.
But part of the problem is recognizing
that there really are bad people in the
world.
They really do mean harm.
They,
they,
they really do behead people and they do
bad things for whatever reason.
They're not all psychopaths.
A lot of them are just morally
motivated.
As I mentioned,
90 percent of the homicides are
moralistic in nature,
but this is true for genocides and,
and ethnic cleansings and pilgrims.
They're morally motivated.
They have,
they have wrong ideas and ideas that
dangerous ever have gestated without
religion because almost all,
if you think,
you know,
holocaust pogroms what's happening right
now in Europe,
all of these things,
there's a religious underpinning to all
of them.
So could this type of math stuff ever
happened without religion?
Well,
it did.
It did in the seventies and a 60
seventies,
eighties with Marxist.
I'm regimes and terrorists.
I mean,
there was a lot of terrorism in the
seventies.
I mean,
way more than now.
A CNN just ran that.
They had those series,
the seventies,
the eighties and so on.
And the one in the seventies,
one of the episodes was just an hour
long of all the terrorist attacks.
I forgot I lived through it,
but I forgot how many there were.
And uh,
you know,
to the point where Monte Python parody
did in the life of Brian People's Gdl
front the front of people's homes.
And yet that's how many there were.
But like that.
And there was a,
you know,
the rates of,
uh,
of murders were much higher and bombings
and in,
in the United States.
Um,
so those are,
but those were moralistically driven,
you know,
but,
but it's,
it's a kind of a,
because Marxism is sort of a quasi
religious.
So what's behind when we say religion,
it's this idea of a Utopian society.
There's a place we can get to either
heaven above or heavens on earth.
We can get there if it weren't for those
people that are stopping us,
the capitalists,
the here is the or the Jews or the
Christians or the,
you know,
whoever it is.
So it's engaging the moral module in the
brain,
whatever that is a to be worked up about
a cause.
I love that concept that it's,
you're always fighting the other,
whoever the other is,
and it can be through the religious
prism or the secular prison event.
It's sort of up to us to figure out
which one we're going to.
Exactly.
And I'm worried about the EU and Germany
because,
you know,
they've been moving in the right
direction of the very poorest borders.
You can travel across all the countries.
Uh,
there's no border checks and it's just
like driving across the United States
now.
It's great.
And,
and they've been kind of much more
economically prosperous because of that
and politically more freedom and more
democracies.
All those things are good.
But now there's this,
I'm afraid,
fearful,
there'll be a backlash.
Close those borders.
Balkan.
I see what's happening right now.
And then,
and then if they abandoned the currency,
the euro as a currency a,
that's going to be bad economically.
All right,
well let's move on.
Let's move off.
Politics are a little bit.
Get to some of the sort of more out
there stuff and find stuff because you
do talk a lot about conspiracy theories.
Uh,
and I've seen you talk about,
you know,
aliens and JFK assassination and all
this stuff.
Um,
it's fun to debunk this stuff,
right?
It sort of fun to think about them.
Uh,
you know,
whether even nine slash 11 thinking,
at least entertaining the ideas,
whatever they may be that our government
did it or this or that,
whatever it is.
It's sort of fun to always entertain
those ideas.
But basically you come down on all this
stuff that I think what Carl Sagan would
say,
that extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence.
Is that,
did I sum up your view on how to deal
with this stuff?
Yes,
absolutely.
The thing with conspiracy theories that
are different than other claims that we
deal with it skeptic is they do happen.
There are conspiracies.
Watergate was a conspiracy in the
assassination of Lincoln was a
conspiracy,
you know,
uh,
and you know,
there's all those stories about the
stuff that Kissinger was orchestrating
and South American dictatorships we
liked this dictator versus like we're
pulling the strings were sending money
arms for hostages,
you know,
all this stuff was going on.
Those are conspiracies,
right?
Definition.
Uh,
and so we have to acknowledge that that
does happen.
But of course,
the to the conspiracy theorist,
the fact that that happened over there,
it means that my pet theory,
but not necessarily,
not all conspiracies.
Uh,
so how do we tell the difference?
What's the criteria?
Well,
that sort of a conspiracy detection kit,
like the Baloney detection kit where you
know,
the more people that have to be
involved,
the less likely the theory is going to
be true because people are incompetent.
They can't keep their mouth shut.
We find out about it.
I remember I was on g Gordon Liddy's
radio show back in the nineties and uh,
he asked me about conspiracies.
I was like,
well,
you know more about it than I do data.
You're the Watergate guy.
I didn't want to say this,
but you couldn't even break into a hotel
room.
I mean,
you know,
people have this vision of,
government says these super powerful
agents that can do anything.
Mostly they're just like bureaucrats at
the DMV.
That's what you're dealing with.
Right?
So in a way it's the same thing as
religion.
The people that are going down the
conspiracy path,
they want some easy answer for an
extremely complex issue that we really
often have no answer
enemies,
not this complex system that no one can
really understand or predict.
It's,
it's 12 guys living in London calling
the shots of the Illuminati.
And they're pulling the strings and
making this happen.
So it is the same thing as religion
because that feels nice if you,
if you could sort of wrap yourself
around that,
that that's how the world actually
operates.
We'd sorted the same thing as saying,
oh,
well there's a god and I'm going to
believe that
it is like a god or committee of gods or
something that's pulling the strings in
it and it grants way more power than
they,
than anybody actually has,
which is what we grant to gods that they
have more power than we have,
otherwise they wouldn't be gods,
you know.
So what's the point of that?
And uh,
so yeah,
we worked through those and now
politically since we've talked about
left and right,
that nine slash 11 is an interesting
take because that seems to be more on
the left,
uh,
and left and right both have their
handpicked conspiracies that they prefer
a,
like,
but the anti-vaxxers tend to be a little
bit of both.
You get antigovernment right?
And then the thing that the government
is in cahoots with big Pharma and then
the left,
it will,
big Pharma is making money off of
vaccines.
So you get a little bit of both,
right?
That's interesting.
Someone like Bill Maher,
I think it's anti-vaxxer for the most
part.
He's firmly on the left,
but
yeah.
So,
but there,
it's,
it's skeptical skepticism of authority.
Which Authority are you skeptical of the
government or,
or,
or the corporations.
And the perception is both have these
incredible amounts of power and studies
on this show.
They really don't have as much power as
we think that they do.
I mean,
ceos come and go and,
and corporations rise and fall much more
than we think that they do.
We think of,
you know,
the microsofts of the world,
even Google Apple,
they will fail.
They will,
you know,
they're on top now.
But this will change just like Ibm,
General Motors,
what,
you know,
and um,
so open.
I was in Berkeley last week,
uh,
that promoting the skeptic book.
I did talk for a KPFA PACIFICA radio,
which is very far left progressive.
And uh,
so it was that this church,
which was kind of wild because big cross
behind me and I was like,
uh,
but there were protesters,
I protesters.
Oh my God,
what is this about,
you know,
when they're handing out literature,
the engineers and architects for nine
slash 11 truth and,
and shermer versus reality.
The building seven could not have color,
you know.
Oh,
I saw you tweet about this.
Yeah.
So they're okay.
This is a.
So this is that the government is
pulling the strings and doing these
things because of oil and the war.
And so it's after the fact reason he's
hindsight by.
So we went to war.
It was a big,
bad idea,
but we did it for oil.
Therefore we must have triggered the war
in the first place.
Don't governments don't.
Conservative and Republican
administrations do those sorts of
things.
Yes.
So do democratic,
you know,
Roosevelt could not get America into the
war to help churchill who he wanted to
help because of the American firsters
were very powerful in the late thirties.
And they could all see the Nazis rising
and Roosevelt and Churchill wanted to do
something about it.
And uh,
but uh,
Charles Lindbergh and the American
firsters were very powerful Pearl Harbor
and a story we're going to reward.
So isn't that an example of using an
event that you didn't orchestrate to do
something politically you want to do?
Sounds like a nice conspiracy theory
that they knew it was going to happen
and they allowed it to.
Right?
So there was two conspiracies about that
and same nine slash 11.
Either either they did it or they knew
it would happen in allowed it to happen
in order to get this political mode.
And so neither of them are true.
And the reason we know this is because,
um,
the,
the evidence that's used in favor of the
conspiracy is all,
all along is hindsight bias is that,
uh,
look,
look at this memo here.
You know,
the famous August ninth memo from
Condoleeza Rice,
you know,
Sama bid line will attack on US soil.
Wow.
How come Bush didn't do about that?
Because there is 10,000
pieces of info like that every week.
And then you're sorting through it and
no one's talking to each other,
you know,
it's just chaos.
So are you ever able to debunk a
conspiracy theory to a point where the
theorists themselves will concede it?
Because that's sort of the fun in it.
There's no end.
Right?
So even if you lay down something that
is just ironclad,
still,
they're going to find some way to get
around that.
I mean,
how often do you win in that,
you know,
when.
No,
uh,
to the people that I'm debating or
talking to probably never,
never.
But we're after is again,
the undecided voters.
The people that are like,
yeah,
what's the story with that?
I heard something about that memo.
Oh,
I see.
And then they.
Okay,
forget it.
Nevermind.
Nothing to that.
And you try to influence them by just
some basic questions.
You know,
like,
I rifled through all the,
all the other things that,
uh,
Islamic terrorists have done,
you know,
London and Madrid and Boston and African
countries and so on and so on.
Are they also part of this vast right
wing conspiracy that the bush?
No,
no,
of course not,
but that particular one,
which is a little bit like,
okay,
we know those crop circles were faked,
but the ones over here,
we don't have videos.
Those are the real ones.
Yeah,
and there's also seems to be a need to
explain things that can't easily be
explained.
So even going back to the Cologne thing
I saw that day,
a fairly well known feminist saying this
was probably the work of
anti-immigration people that allow,
you know what I mean,
that allowed this open because she
didn't want to really deal with the
world as it was and deal with the
difficult questions related to
immigration and race and religion and
all of that stuff.
So instead,
and you kind of use it for your own
purposes and then you just open up
another conspiracy theory and then that
gets retweeted enough and then you've
opened up a whole other.
Yeah.
So in that case it's okay to just call
bullshit.
Just that.
Well,
that's what I did.
This is a bridge too far.
Yeah.
Let's do a little more on politics
though,
because you consider yourself
a libertarian,
correct?
Yes.
It's more of an issues guy,
but I've leaned libertarian most of my
life since college and uh,
but I've changed my mind in a certain
issues that libertarians are not too
happy about.
And the,
and the reason I'm avoid using the term
so much now a is because um,
it pigeon,
it pigeonholes you into a category in
which you're in and then it makes it
more like a religion.
Like,
okay,
so libertarian,
so you can't believe in any gun
controls.
Right?
It's like,
well,
no,
actually I think maybe background checks
are a good idea in the magazine clip
should be a certain,
you know,
just a few things,
it's like you've abandoned us,
you know,
like what do we have tried,
right.
It's like a ride or you're Republican in
name only.
You're a,
your,
a line or something.
Yeah,
exactly.
Right.
These are the,
these are the points.
You have to hold to all of them or else
you're not in our tribe.
Okay.
So,
well maybe I don't want to be in the
tribe.
Maybe I just want to look at issues.
And what I like about Libertarians is I
don't like either the far right or far
left and so sort of pushes toward the
more of the middle.
I guess the spectrum,
the problem with the spectrum is that
it's not really a spectrum like that.
You know,
there's other places you could be more
of a peer,
a diamond shaped,
uh,
but nevertheless,
um,
that and things like climate change,
you know,
it's like we're supposed to be against a
believer in climate change because we're
pro capitalists.
It's like,
wait,
either it's getting warmer,
it's not.
This is just an empirical question.
It has nothing to do with politics.
Yeah.
Does that show you?
That's a good example of how politics
and religion and just rationality and
irrationally it all gets mucked up.
So I hear you because a lot of people,
you know,
I've always considered myself a liberal
and now I see,
I get emails and tweets everyday people
going,
ah,
Dave's on his way to becoming a
libertarian because I will always stand
up for liberty.
And I believe that the individual
person,
ultimately,
I think you could know for gay marriage
for example,
while I can defend it from a liberal
point of view,
because I think people should be allowed
to marry who they want.
It's also very easily defended by a
libertarian point of view,
right?
Or,
or medical marijuana or things like
that.
So that's a place where I like that.
I think classic liberals and
Libertarians can sort of come together.
And I do think that that concept is sort
of where politics should go in general.
Absolutely.
I mean,
Dr King made the point about gay
marriage back when people were saying,
Oh,
you shouldn't get involved in that back
in the sixties.
And,
uh,
in a.
and he said,
no,
our freedom is wrapped up in their
freedom.
You know,
if you can suppress somebody because of
this particular way that they are,
then you can suppress them for other
category.
We want freedom across the board.
And that's right,
that's the principle.
Yeah.
So is that idea though a really what's
so dangerous about identity politics?
Because it's not what Dr King said that
we have to protect everybody else.
It's actually identity politics,
like we got to protect ourselves.
And then what happens is everyone else
is sort of secondary.
It's just tribalism.
It's just,
you know,
this is our tribe.
These are what the things we believe.
Even like the humanism,
when I got involved in the whole
skeptics movement,
uh,
in the late eighties,
early nineties,
and I thought,
well,
I'm a humanist.
And then I,
you know,
I started reading the humanist magazines
and going to their conferences and
Italian,
but I could clearly see they had a list
of talking points that were just clearly
right down the straight political left.
And it's like,
well,
what about these things over here?
You know?
Oh,
it was the evil Republicans.
Evil Conservatives.
Like,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
I thought you were a humanist.
Just science reason you stay out of
politics.
But again,
we're just,
we're political animals.
You know,
we just want to be tribal.
And so,
and you know libertarians,
you know,
it's like hurting cats.
You know,
we're never going to be a big party.
So I'm not even sure if it's a
worthwhile label.
Yeah,
I'd love to figure out a way to sort of
get those principles out there more even
though I don't as you know,
as I just said,
I don't need the label for myself,
but I think you can make a lot of strong
moral arguments.
Not using religion.
Yes.
Through the Libertarian Lens
language matters.
So,
you know,
maybe we're in,
we were in favor of liberty and aren't
you in favor of liberty and freedom?
Yeah.
That sounds good.
We're trying a new one on instead of gun
control.
Gun Safety.
I believe in gun safety.
I think people should be trained if they
have a gun,
I think they should keep their gun
locked up safely.
Don't you agree?
You know,
anyone in the NRA should go,
well,
yes,
of course.
That's what our organization is.
Gun Safety.
That's why they were founded,
but control it makes it sound like
you're trying to control my freedom.
You're going to control my individuality
and that feels wrong.
You know?
So the language does matter.
I think how we use these things.
And
so the kind of arguments kind of
interesting because I think there is a
certain element of conspiracy theory
with the people,
the people that are totally pro gun to
the point that you should be allowed to
have whatever it is you want and that
one day you're gonna have to rise up and
fight the government and all that stuff.
I understand,
you know,
I've sat on the show many times like I
get it.
We left England because we didn't want
to live under a king and a tyrannical
government and no tax agent was an agent
and all that stuff.
Um,
but there's an element of conspiracy to
that,
that the government is coming to get
these people,
right?
So the more that the government tries to
get their guns,
the more they want their guns,
right?
So isn't that because Lee cycle,
how do we break that?
Obama has sold more guns.
I mean,
they say that constantly,
right?
So how do,
how do we break that cycle?
Um,
well I think,
I think we need to get to organizations
like the NRA and say,
you've,
you've gone down the wrong path.
You know,
you really should be in favor of safety
and these are the kinds of things that
we need to have background checks.
I mean,
just change the conversation.
So.
So you're in favor of a terrorist
getting guns for free and killing people
in America.
You think that that should be.
Well,
no,
no.
They should be to.
Well,
how can you tell if they're a terrorist
or not?
I mean we just have to have background
checks for everybody.
They're not going to tell you at the
border.
Yeah,
I'm coming here to kill Americans,
you know?
So uh,
you know,
you need the general principles.
And what about,
you know,
air let anybody fly.
Airplane.
Well No,
they should be licensed.
Of course they should be licensed.
So I try,
I try to use those arguments and also
take the approach like I do with,
with uh,
Christians.
You know,
I used to be one now used to be a
Christian.
You are a Christian.
Yeah.
What happened?
Okay.
So then at least they're listening.
You know,
I used to be against all gun control.
I had guns,
I grew up with guns.
I had a,
I had a uh,
uh,
a handgun in my home for 20 years,
you know,
but you know,
I got to change your mind.
You change your mind.
I started reading and thinking about it
and look at these studies and so on and
so to open the door to a conversation,
but guns are almost tell asthmatic now.
They're almost like religious icons of
representing freedom and liberty and God
and Jesus and I don't know,
it's all wrapped up in a package now
that people just lose their minds when
you talk about it.
So as long as we're talking guns,
let's knock out a couple other just hot
button political things and see if we
can figure out the moral argument for
them before we wrap up.
So something like abortion,
which as a general rule,
I'm for the woman being able to make
decisions about her body.
But at the same point I would understand
that having an abortion at a,
at eight months or seven months or even
six months in my opinion,
are definitely destroying a human life.
Now,
if your people don't want to have that
conversation,
right,
people are afraid to have that
conversation.
So what,
what moral argument can you make that is
for,
I assume you're,
I'm guessing you're for abortion.
Actually I don't have.
So your approach is,
so what's one piece of a.
that's why language matters,
but what moral argument can you make
that for abortion that also understands
that at some point before that thing
leaves the woman's body.
It is a life at the same point.
Well,
I think the law is tracked this fairly
closely to our intuitions that,
you know,
a third trimester abortion is wrong,
the gray area in the second trimester.
No Gregory and the first trimester kind
of tracking our sense about whether it's
an individual or not,
is that a person that's thinking,
cognizant can feel and suffer.
And um,
and so there,
I think you could make the case.
I try to,
in the moral arc that,
um,
that,
that the freedom of adult women to have
control and choice over their own bodies
slightly trumps the rights or whatever
of the fetus.
Just barely a,
I'm not pro abortion,
I am pro choice and it would be better
if you know,
if the numbers got down,
but if a but on that,
if it's our goal to decrease the number
of abortions,
the best thing you can do is get women
educated,
prosperous,
and access to birth control and the
numbers just go down.
Right.
That's where we really failed as a
society,
right?
Yeah.
Because the same people that don't want
abortions also cut sex education and
then it's like,
well,
you know,
and then they cut social services so
people feel like if they're going to
have a kid and not have money for it,
well they don't want that kid.
So it's like,
again,
it's another one of these never ending
cycles.
And the other argument I make in the
moral arc is it historical and that has
historically men have always lorded it
over.
Women,
particularly about sex and paternity and
so on.
And just,
if you just look at the history of
marriage and the history of men and
women's relationships for thousands of
years,
it's always men trying to control women
and there's good evolutionary reasons
for this.
Pinker argues about this in,
in the blank slate,
you know,
whole chapter on sex and all that stuff
and you know,
men are obsessed with controlling
women's sexuality and this is one of the
big things that have helped the women's
movement is to,
is to break that,
those chains and give women the freedom.
So that's my final argument is that in
addition to the rights of the fetus
selling all those,
but,
but just in the long run,
it's better to give women more freedom
than less end to end to keep men out of
that area of control.
Yeah.
So that sounds like it would line up
with some libertarian values pointedly.
Yeah.
The liberty of the woman.
So most libertarians are pro choice for
sure.
So there's a few,
like Ron Paul,
who was sort of considered himself a
libertarian,
but he's Christian.
So see there,
you see that interesting conflict.
So he was a gynecologist,
right,
because he is a guy in the bottom.
So that,
that's,
that's a lot,
you know,
there's,
so again,
Libertarians are all over the board,
you know,
there's,
there's plenty of atheist libertarians,
but there's plenty of believers or are
just in the middle.
They're not religious at all.
And,
and they're also very much split on
foreign policy,
you know,
should we be isolationists or do we need
to go help people that need help,
you know,
so.
Well,
like Rand Paul,
he was very isolationist his father even
more so.
Uh,
so I,
I get those arguments,
uh,
but on the other hand,
don't we have a moral obligation to help
people whose own freedoms and liberties
are being oppressed by a tyrannical
dictators?
Yes,
we do.
Yeah.
Okay.
So this is what that split in the left
they were talking about earlier.
It's really a hugely about what can we
do and are we imposing our values and
all that.
But let,
let's,
let's just do one more and then we got
to wrap up.
So I want to talk about a moral argument
you can make on the economic level I
think is really interesting.
Uh,
you know,
when you hear people talking about what
Bernie wants to tax everybody at 90
percent,
we know it's not 90 percent.
It's a progressive tax,
so it's not,
you know,
without getting into too much into the
numbers there,
but it's not really taxing you at 90
percent.
It progressively increases versus a flat
tax.
Can you make a moral argument for
economics?
That makes sense?
Uh,
I'm not sure absolutely across the
board,
but um,
but the idea of running different
experiments were say different states in
the 50 states have different tax systems
and you can kind of look at the outcome
of what happens socially in that and
economically in that particular state.
You know,
does it become more or less prosperous
with the progressive tax versus a flat
tax?
I would actually like to see some states
just do a straight flat tax and just see
what happens or maybe try it for awhile,
you know,
maybe maybe we should abolish the irs,
do with straight 16 and a half percent,
whatever it was a,
I think the cruise wants that.
Right?
So let's see what happens,
you know,
run the experiment and we can always go
back.
Uh,
you know,
so I'm in favor of just trying different
things on a lot of those things.
I'm not sure that there's an absolute
single answer here.
I like Sam's a metaphor of the multiple
peaks on the moral landscape.
Uh,
so how do we decide which peak is right?
You can't.
There is no,
there's no right peak is right for you.
So this is kind of the libertarian
argument.
You know,
you want to paint your house red with a
purple door,
fine.
But in our neighborhood we don't like
the houses that look like that.
They all look the same.
That's,
that's what we like in this
neighborhood.
But that neighborhood over there make it
topanga where everybody has these wild
hippie homes.
Okay,
fine.
So you have different communities that
live different ways and you know,
I don't like the argument.
Well just if you don't like America then
leave,
go to Mexico if you like.
Well you know,
come on,
my friends are here,
my family's here,
my kids are gonna.
Come on,
let's see if we can do local politics
and just run different experiments.
Yeah.
And often if you're complaining about it
the most,
it means you care the most.
So yes.
Well hopefully.
What was it?
I could have done this for another three
hours so you're definitely going to have
to come back because I barely got to any
of this stuff on my note card.
So I thank you.
And I want to thank Michael Shermer for
joining me and you can check out his
work@skepticdotcomanditMichaelShermer.com.
Correct.
Alright,
there you go.
We'll do it again next week.
Thanks.